America might actually be ready for a
gay president
some people say we've had a gay
president or two but yeah a new poll is
showing that we might actually be ready
for it this is by Pew Research Center
for the people impressed let's take a
look the majority of Americans 66% say
it wouldn't matter for presidential
candidate was gay or lesbian that's nice
27% say they would be less likely to
support a gay or lesbian candidate while
5% would be more likely and in 2007
nearly half said they would be less
likely to vote for a gay or lesbian
candidate so this doesn't really
surprise me that much a lot of good gay
stuff has been happening just in the
last week what we get one of these
activist judges they took down
Pennsylvania is now gonna have gay
marriage and Oregon so yeah good gay
things are happening want you to have a
segment called good gay stuff good gay
stuff good guys who could be the token
straight guy yeah president as the
ambassador for the lesbian community you
must feel good about this you could now
run you can now be president hi this is
actually I actually planned this segment
to take a moment to talk to the American
people about my run 2014 no I feel
really excited about that I said I gave
no specifics about your which means it's
gonna be good it's good no I think I
think it is very telling of where we're
coming in this country I think we've
made huge steps leaps forward really in
the past couple years and I think now
people are realizing it doesn't matter
who you are you're probably going to
[ __ ] up you know yeah I get it yeah
we've had plenty of straight presidents
and they've still managed to [ __ ] us yes
so you know I mean now you better issue
your apology why I think that's great
yeah I think that's a good I think
that's the joke that's why I mean
president yeah right that's another
thing
no he's never gonna get nothing that
could be you will get shafted here do
you think so I think it's obviously
great right of course it is so yes well
maybe we'll have a gay president
probably within our lifetimes fantastic
do you think the biggest hurdle actually
will be the the public display of
affection thing because that's still the
part that is not shown for gay people
even though there's been a huge you know
what it's really awkward to watch most
presidents be official like I mean I
think Obama's the first one that kind of
has like some swag with his lady first
lady yeah but you know george w bush
that was weird it's like an awkward I'm
like what is their sex like you remember
that horrible out Al Gore kiss remember
god bless Al Gore I remember that Gore
it was that that was mm yeah it was that
one where it was like listen I'm not a
robot I'm sexual as hell and he did it
and it was just so gross and long yeah
and it was just strange and I get that I
mean and and there's this I don't think
that anyone is being those those public
displays of affection regardless of
gender like I think those are still kind
of creepy no man and I think everyone
finds like a middle ground where if it's
like a taste will display then it's okay
then it's tasteful but it's it's hard to
define it ahead of time but once then it
goes overboard you kind understand yeah
we're agreed that that's pretty gross no
matter who it is do you think it would
be easier to have a gay male or a
lesbian
first my gut feeling is we probably have
a lesbian first why Hillary Clinton know
it might be easier but then we're
talking we're not only electing our
first woman but she's gonna be a lesbian
hey again I'm running for president
now I think it's possible I mean I don't
know I'm one hand I feel like people
would be more apt to you know vote for a
man I don't know I mean historically
it's been the case but I think people
will feel more uncomfortable with seeing
that kind of right I just feel like I
can see emotions
uncomfortable with having a gay leader
that guy yeah we're always with the
shirt like where are we is this with
Hollywood what are we doing yeah yeah
yeah no you Justin Bieber yeah all right
well that note that Putin's gay